Now I would be remiss in talking about strategic alliances
not to talk about the greatest strategic alliance ever made,
and that was Steve Jobs at Apple when he built the iPod.
Jobs understood that the iPod hardware was a wonderful device,
but without software, iTunes, it was still just another piece of iron.
But, even when they had the hardware and software ecosystem,
they were still missing the content, the music, that would go on it.
For 100 years, record labels had held that content so tightly,
allowing no one else access,
but there was a moment in time with Napster
and the record labels feeling threatened
that Jobs understood there was an opportunity to strike strategic alliances
that no one else had been able to do.
In fact, the rest is history.
The iPod, the iPhone, the resurgence of Apple,
music available to everybody and anybody in their pockets
to billions of people was, in fact, a strategic alliance.